good morning everyone okay so my name is
David Higgins and this is Robert
Schwartz we're going to give you the
tutorial on Julia the new numerical
computing language
we're slightly surprised to see so many
people in the room necessarily
especially given how the weather has
been the last 24 hours in Berlin and
before it disappears from the screen we
have the github repository address here
if you clone that to your computer
you'll have access to both the notebooks
that we're using and two HTML versions
of them so if anyone's really struggling
to get Julia working on their machine
you can just follow on the HTML file so
cut it copy that quickly or get rid of
one of your neighbors I think many
people have already cloned us for that
matter if anyone hasn't realized your
Wi-Fi password is on the back of your ID
here so you can connect to the network
and you can download everything we're
going to try and do this in an
interactive manner and we we posted it
as an intermediate tutorial also it's
the PI data conference so we expect that
most of you have a some decent level of
programming experience but you probably
have zero experience of Julia so in a
sense we're going to try and do the A to
Z while keeping people interested also
with more advanced topics so let's just
test what is the size like for people
here do I need to zoom this more can I
put it put up your hands if you really
if you really need me to do an extra
zoom on the on the fonts here one person
is standing this then come up the front
we we have two or three seats still here
along the side if you guys if it's
literally only you guys I'd like to keep
as much obviously a screen space
available as possible so I don't want to
over zoom either so how many people have
a real problem here and I need to
actually increase the zoom nobody now
because I've bullied you okay thanks
seven so Julia what is it it's a
scripted programming language so since
we're we're assuming you have some kind
of Python knowledge and your data
science is something like that
the big selling points of it are that
it's easy to write like pison you would
say it's fast and it's been designed
from the ground up for a numerical
processing and so Python was not
designed around numerix you need to use
all of your libraries you need to use
numpy and so on in order to do numerix
properly in python julia has been
designed by some people who previously
worked on optimizing supercomputer work
and for a numerical processing and they
decided to design a new language and
they decided to design it in a way that
you write at once and you can run as
anywhere so I hate the phrase they use
what they call it the two-two language
problem so you you can write it in this
language as with simple scripts and as
you need more and more speed gains you
can modify your script and you can put
in extra details and you can get more
speed out of your system the other thing
that they concentrated on was
parallelization we're going to do a bit
of that at the ends but we're actually
going to do fairly advanced
parallelization using OpenCL the inbuilt
parallelization is not stable yet so
it's coming it's more or less there at
this point but the new release of julia
only came out last week so that's
probably the version you're using and
it's the version we're using for the
tutorial but we're far from expert
sinners at this point okay so the
outline of the workshop I'm going to
give the introduction section so just
how to get up and running with juliet
but only two or three words I mean you
need to figure out how to install it
yourself effectively a overview of the
basics of the language so if we just
dive in and see how we play with it from
a numerical point of view from a
programming point of view how do we use
how would you compare it with python and
matlab and c depending on your
backgrounds i don't have such a strong
background in r so you're going to have
to bridge that gap yourself and what is
it about julia that's different what is
it what is the key component that makes
it Julia as opposed to a different
language what gives it the power then
robert's going to take over introducing
the package ecosystem so this is
extremely powerful and I mean the thing
that got me and still
language was someone told me I could use
any Python library in us which is
wonderful but he's going to use Julia
specific libraries and give you some
worked examples from a data science
perspective so hopefully that will be of
interest to the majority of people in
the room and then the last part is what
I'm calling speed and accuracy and
that's me again so you can call C code
natively you can call Fortran code
natively I've used open CL in my work
and so I'm going to show how to do that
we can look at things like timing and
benchmarking your codes and profiling it
I have code here for debugging but with
the new release the debugger is not
working yet so joy but the code is there
and we can talk our way through it
briefly if we have time the idea is
roughly 20 minutes of actual talking per
section and up to 10 minutes of
questions and that brings us right up to
the the full hour and 30 minutes it's
free though in the sense that if people
are getting really bored with the easy
stuff we can move faster I've fills the
notebooks here because ultimately to
code cater to this group of people it's
hard to judge what you need to know in
fact it's impossible because you're all
on different levels and so there's a lot
in here and I'll just run through the
code I'll talk over it you can play with
it after there's also stuff down the
bottom of the notebooks which you can
play with afterwards on your own for
advanced features and so on
and we can see how far we get if we if
we run outta time on the speed stuff
it's not so relevant if that's where we
get stuck with it with the group but the
code is there for you to play with so
just a few quick notes on how to get
julia in the first place on your system
so Julia lying org is the website and
they have downloads they have downloads
for Windows for Mac OS for Linux I think
also for ARM processors they certainly
compose for it
Linux distributions do have it in the
repositories but it's not always so
up-to-date so you should check what
version you're using if you're getting
it from a repo and then there's two kind
of online solutions julia box which one
or two other people
are attempting to use provides cloud
hosting of Jupiter style notebooks using
Giulia as the backends and so that's a
that's hosted now on Google cloud and I
think for now it's largely free its they
were considering app a model at one
stage and they seem to have stepped back
from that that is set up by the people
behind the language they've also set up
a company called Giulia confusing and
they have a product called Giulia pro I
don't work for them I've never used the
product but it's there in order to
provide corporate supports and to give a
way of getting the language into into
corporate environments so today we're
using julian 0.6 which like I said only
came out a week ago we're going to run
it in Jupiter notebooks yeah so like I
said you could one or two you are going
to try and run it on Julia Box we're not
we haven't actually tested it's there
but it is just a jupiter notebook that
we're using so you should be able to
copy and paste this stuff over and i
think you can even throw on the
repository and but i'm not sure how to
do that you will need some packages so
in there if you clone the repository
this is notebook 0 0 that i'm looking at
right now and these commands here if you
if you run them if you execute them in
julia will install all of the libraries
that we're using the packages and if you
type using for each of them it will then
compile various back-end requirements so
many of them have c and or and so on in
the background doing fast processing and
so on a lot of them use homebrew at the
moment and this will compile all of that
it'll take a while if you haven't done
it already feel free to go ahead and
start but it will take 10 to 15 minutes
yeah like I said I'll be using OpenCL I
kept it separate here open CL has its
own requirements which we'll discuss
when we come to it
we'll see if you're actually able to get
it working but I have the worked
examples already in the HTML versions of
the notebooks right how do you actually
use julia so there's a raffle the read
eval print loop so that's if you just
run julia and you get a command line and
so you can type in a command
you'll see the output basically the
command line itself is where you run
Julia and then a file name so it's like
Python my files up does whatever the PI
so this would be the sort of standard
way of running a program you can route
use Jupiter notebooks using the I Julia
package and the other thing that they're
working on is is the the IDE the the
text editor assam and they're using a
package with it they call juno and this
is this is very nice i just have it open
here i would say it's not quite usable
yet i mean it is but it's not perfect
but the idea is to give you something
like matlab or to give you something
like Mathematica so you can just type in
commands here and it will give you the
answer there and you see I created in my
test fire and I've got a workspace here
with the with the test variable value
and you can plot down here it's it's
it's fine but I don't personally use it
my typical use at the moment is to open
the repple and then to import the file
that I'm working on so I type the file
in Assam and I save it and then I just
use an import command which I think
we're not covering today ironically but
it's ok ok so the language what is it
it's dynamically typed much like python
so python when you run it it every time
you every time it comes to a line it has
to interpret what the type of each of
the variables is before it decides what
to do with them here you like like pipes
and you don't have to tell it's the type
of the variable but it in fares it in a
different manner and so it knows it
roughly speaking at runtime so it's able
to compile the code and then it runs at
C speeds so you don't actually have to
tag that this is an int and this is a
float but you get that level of speed
boost of a compiled language because of
how it infers us so that's what I mean
by optional types optional types you can
tag it yourself as well and you can tell
it ok well I'm only working here with
arrays of float 60
and then it will know to specialized for
that the building types in the base
language are equivalent to user-defined
types so this is really nice from a
performance point of view that if you
write your own type some kind of
abstract type where you accumulate a lot
of days in US or whatever there's no
performance cost to that compared to
using the built-in types it's just in
time compiles using LLVM that's the
thick compiler it uses something they
call dynamic multiple dispatch which I
will mention briefly or I will actually
use in my section it's got Mesa
programming you can call C and Fortran
libraries natively you can compile
against them basically and like I said
the thing that convinced me was you can
call Python libraries via a package they
call pi call and when you run your code
what happens is julia converts it into
an intermediate representation and then
LLVM compiles that for your machine and
that's what actually runs this gives a a
two speed cut a two-level operation in a
sense where the first time you compile
is it can be slower so when they
benchmark they like to compile it once
and then for the real run they'll
they'll do it a second time and only
time the second run I would say from our
point of view as data scientists that
somewhat cheating because we tend to
only run our code once when it actually
works but anyway that's the design of
the language so I'm going to close that
notebook we go to the the main one for
my section soup where is it yes okay so
the approach I'm taking here is good
I'm treating it as if I'm coming to the
language and I've been told that it's
I've been told what I've told you guys
just now so you know that it's this sort
of scripted language you know that it's
good for numerix and you start playing
with it how can I get this to work okay
let's keep let me just zoom out one for
a second okay okay so I told you it's
good at math let's just try out some
basic maths I'm going to sit down
because it's a little easier for me to
type maybe you could keep an eye out for
questions so I mean I just I just did a
equals ten and it doesn't output a
equals ten great I try printing it I can
print the value and it comes out here I
try printing something more advanced two
different print statements and you've
got interpolation here where you've got
the dollar a being interpolated as the
value and I've also got this print
statement where I separate the different
parts and they both seem to work fine
okay what about a floating-point number
so I've got B is fifteen point three and
again that seems to work what if I add
the two and save them to a variable name
simple sum and we get twenty five point
three so that seems to work like I
understand this is too simple for most
of the people but you kind of need to
see it once too if you've never used the
language what about trying out a basic
math function like exponential so I can
calculate the exponential of BiBi was
15.3 and i save it as this value simple
math function so I'm getting four by ten
to the six and I can do a slightly more
complicated thing I can say the result
of my calculation is a plus B times that
value I printed out and the output of my
calculation is that value and so the
first thing I want to point out here is
I did an extra calculation after I did
one plus one just at the end and you see
the output in the Julia notebook is
actually two
but the print statement appears up here
so basically there's there's two things
going on here I've put in this semicolon
here which suppresses output if you're
only what running one line but if you're
running multiple lines only the last
line actually gets printed to the screen
so if I suppress the one plus one we now
no longer get that out part we just get
we just get the stuff that was in the
print statement so it's kind of how
would I put it it's it's optional it's
only really relevant on the the repple
and here in jupiter notebooks if you're
running things as a program all of the
output is suppressed unless you do some
kind of print statements so what about
trying some more advanced math functions
I can design tan hyperbolic tangents and
it all works the show is a is a macro
here where it does a very nice thing
where it actually prints the the
arguments that I said and equals the
actual value that it returns so this is
a very handy way rather than doing print
statements for all of your your inline
debugging okay so I left a few cells
blank if you want to try out some other
mathematical functions basically as you
we any good functions that people like
it okay so two to the power of 10 works
yep good point
so um yeah you can't you want to take
this do okay okay so I just left those
free for you to play with but we can we
continue moving if people want to ask
questions please just raise your hands
and we will keep an eye out so we want
to assign some variables typically you
just use the equal sign to assign a
variable under the hood it's typically
passed by reference to functions and
it's all variables are holding
references to literal
in the system so we've got something
here at the linspace function just like
in MATLAB or in numpy and so here we've
got from 1 to 10 in steps of 1 this
format here is actually new in this
version so it's using a generator now
which it wasn't before so I can do the
type of that variable and it's using
something they call a step range Len
where it holds float64 in this
particular example what if I look at the
type of some of the other variables that
I previously created so I've got some
tuples here in the output we could
ignore that for now but we see that a
was 10 and the type of it was an in 64
so I told you that types are inferred
here it's not me that sets them at this
point now as I said B to 21
I see that B is 21 and I get an int for
B but if I set B back to 15.3 I see that
it's now interpreting it as a float so
there's basically 99% of what you want
to do with types is automatically
handled and it automatically converts it
to the appropriate type that you will
need yeah so we'll see in terms of the
the the passed by reference this will
come into play when we want to see
whether we want to change the value of a
type of a variable or not so we can
create a value here C using this
notation as well which for me at least
speaks of MATLAB so one in steps of 2 up
to 10 in this case it does not know it
it does not include the last number
right yeah well yeah the output so the
type of this variable here is a step
range which is the more common one
rather than this step range Len which
came out of the linspace
we're moving more and more to generators
in Python for all of these things so
there they're evaluated later so that's
why it has this kind of strange type
it's got various field names that you
can
and it's got a start value a step size
and a stop value you can iterate over it
basically using these values and we can
access any value using the square
bracket notation so the third element
and we're indexing from one here not
from zero is five so this one was going
from one to nine in steps of 2 and so
the third elements of that was 5 &
Collect so there's a there's a help
function which you can use a question
mark to access so collect is a function
which basically goes over a collection
or an iterator and gathers all the
elements of it it collects them and so
we're going to collect the entries of
that of that generator and we now get an
array so we get a one dimensional array
here of in 64's we get the elements 1 3
5 7 & 9 and we can see the type of that
is an array okay what about creating
maybe a string so if I want to make a
string I can do my string is and I've
got a string now so I can I can print
that out I can I can try adding a number
to it what would that do so like I said
we're just playing with the language to
see what happens this one this one is
not going to work unfortunately so it
doesn't know how to do that kind of
concatenation so the the best way that I
know to do it is to just use the string
command and you're creating it out of
these elements so now I've got a string
from the string that I created in that
variable and a second variable here and
so that's the that's the easiest way I
know for doing some concatenation yeah
so we've got a raise and basically near
algebra so we can create an array of
four ones so notice here that this is
this is a vector it's a one-dimensional
array it's
not you might expect that it would be
4x4 but rather you use the second
argument to create 4x4 so here we're
using R and we've got a the matrix a is
a matrix of 4x4 elements each one of
them is a random number I can access the
first elements using a 1 if I want so
it's the stop the top left corner here
everything is column-major in in julia
for anyone who's interested indexing is
not from 0 so that will give a bound
there you can use the second dimension
so 1/2 would be row 1 column 2 so that
would be this entry here now point 2 7 5
end accesses the final elements in the
array and unfortunately there's no -1
access so that is a very nice feature in
python that unfortunately has not made
it across you can also do very slicing
and broadcasting so I'm using one to end
in steps of 2 here and on both on both
dimensions I can create an empty vector
in a sense I can create memory here
using the vector function for floats and
that's 5 5 elements these are the values
here are relevant because I haven't
initialized them yet so ones was
initialized in them all to one this is
just basically saying give me some
memory I can do something similar with
with matrices so I can create a matrix
of floats and it's 4 times 2 in its
dimensions I can do another one here
which has no dimensions so this is an
interesting one for when we when we do
the multiple dispatch so the multiple
dispatch works on types so you need to
know the type in advance so here I'm
setting a variable to have a type but
it's got 0 memory allocation so the
while these ones are creating memory
that you can immediately access and edit
this one has no memory as this has no
memory assigned to it it's just as a
type so if I try to access the first
element of Z I get no access I the
it's the set index won't work on that if
I try accessing the size of the vector
the matrix and the empty the zero matrix
I get the first one has dimension 5 the
second one has four by two and the third
one again provokes an error we have
power cables if anyone needs them and
the yes so in terms of assigning to Z
then you can't say element five of Z is
now given this value so you but you can
reassign Z to a new matrix so here I've
got the matrix containing one two three
in a column and Z is now pointing at
that you can have any type of array so
this is like a vector of vectors and
it's got three elements in the in the
outer vector and the inner vectors have
different lengths so we've got a vector
of length three vector of length two and
a vector of length three and that's
totally okay in the India raised here
and finally in terms of memory access we
have I said V so this is my matrix W
here I've said V equals W now if I
access element one of V I can change it
so element one of W was one two three
and now I'm saying one four five of V so
what happens here I print out W and it's
now got one four or five and so this is
the for the people who are over the less
object-oriented background this is this
is the referencing model that's used for
the memory so V is just getting what a
shallow copy of the of the matrix W it's
just getting a pointer to us to its
memory space so you have deep copy which
you might know from from MATLAB for
instance which would copy over the
entire array so V and W here both have
one four five in the first row I now do
a deep copy of W to V and I change the
first row of V to one two three
but when I print W now it still has one
four five because they're now in
separate
memory spaces we made an entire copy of
W in and then pointed VSS and so I I
don't need to do a collect here but I'm
just doing it for visualization so I'm
creating a range from one to five and
I'm collecting the elements and
basically giving myself an array of the
elements from one two one two five Y can
create the identity matrix a five
dimensional identity matrix so in this
case I don't need a second argument
because the identity matrix obviously
has to be square here and a little bit
of again playing with the notation the
ex-prime is a transpose times y so a
vector x times the identity matrix gives
us back the vector in this case the
vector was already transposed before we
did the multiplication so we get a row
vector there's also a function called
transpose so it's up to you whether you
use the little layer that is Mackerras
here or whether you use the the
transpose function and then I can edit a
couple of elements of Y so just this is
for an example I've made this one here
one and this one here one as well as
long as well as the diagonals so the Row
one column two and Row 2 Row Row two
column one and if I multiply that using
the dust notation now so we've got a
vector transpose Delta times the Y we
see this kind of element wise operation
so this is just to show how that how
that operates so we had one two three
four five in our row vector multiplied
by this almost identity matrix and we
see now that we get one two three four
five across the columns and and down we
just get the repetition so it's a
broadcast basically of the of the of the
vector elements yeah so you've seen me
create some random numbers already so
here I'm just creating five times one
array I can index them so I'm looking
here to create an index
for all the elements where the value is
greater than not 0.5 and I get a bit
array so this is something that I've
done in the past a lot in in MATLAB
where I need to look at which elements
are greater than a certain value so the
first two in this example were greater
than not 0.5 and the last 3 were less
than is less than or equal to that the
does is important here because it's
element wise you can access the elements
of K that are greater than that value by
just embedding this but then you only
get the two values and you don't know
where they where anymore which
mathematically can sometimes be quite
difficult then a long way of doing it
would be to create it creates this sort
of vector of values wherever the index
is true
so I've got the values 1 wherever that
that thing was true and 0 elsewhere the
bit array you can't really use for maps
so you need to do something like this
but there is a filter function which I
would encourage you to look up if you
actually go down this route because it
is more efficient than this it's
numerically considerably more efficient
I'm flow of control so we've got boolean
true and false we can do a while loop so
we're just generating a random number
and if the random number is less than
0.5 we said G to false and then the next
time you come round to the top of the
loop you Alexis because it's now false
so we see a bunch of numbers being
printed here and at some point the 50
second time second time through the loop
we said g2 false we print the value 53
because it goes all the way to the end
of the loop and then we exit the while
loop we can also use a break statement
instead so this will exit directly at
the break line you don't come round to
when G is equal to false again this this
line here will never occur in this
particular code so we go down to the end
it's about to break and then it's done
there's this Python style indexing so
for elements in the matrix a prints the
elements so I've lost the dimensions of
a here but I'm just looping through them
we've got here
a comprehension which is kind of nice so
inside these square brackets so I print
the value I for I in one two three I can
create an entire matrix very efficiently
here by using this notation so I
generate the values over here I can loop
over over two things at once like a loop
over I and J using a single for
statements and generate the values here
and then they get assigned begets
assigns to point towards them yup
well because if I if I leave it in you
also get this output here so it's
because I'm using print inside the loop
and the loop runs three times yeah good
question okay so I can also create
inside a for loop here and so the the
important thing to notice here the
comprehension is very nice for creating
B whereas inside the for loop I need to
already assign some memory for C so I in
my case I just create a matrix of ones
and then I I do the values whereas here
I don't need to pre assign pre-allocate
B it just gets done as part of the
comprehension so we can see the values
of C here yeah there's a super nice
example from the Giulia language blog
where they've embedded they've had a
couple here being generators inside a
comprehension and they're looping over
for different things and so the thing I
want you to notice here is that the last
thing gets done first so it's like
nested loops where the last one in the
list here inside the comprehension is
the innermost loop and then you you you
scale outwards I can also do a
comprehension inside this function call
so I'm looking at the extrema and the
comprehension is to get the sum of all
of the tuples for for each tuple in that
in that list here which was called
change and so yeah the sum the extrema
the minimum and the maximum are hundreds
just because that's what the example was
we can also just do the most simple for
which I just wanted to demonstrate here
okay yeah thirds to ternary operator
yeah uh so yeah I would be but I can't
remember off the top of my head what
they what they what the function is I
mean you can clearly do the trick I did
with the indexing where you would just
do things square brackets does equals
the actual extremal value hmm yeah yeah
I I there there there was definitely a
function but I don't use extremists so I
don't know what it is there's elsif
which I didn't show you there's no do
loop as far as I'm aware okay
oh okay so for those who are late we've
written up the github address here if
anyone needs to clone the notebooks and
the HTML files
it's just up on the top right of the
whiteboard okay I apologize if this is
slightly boring but it's sort of to give
the the overview of the language so
you're all on the same page even if we
only do Robert's a really nice example
after that that's already a really good
introduction to the language but I mean
a lot of this is basic but even if you
were learning this at home you would
have to go through them one by one just
to know these details so I can create a
function the function I called foo it
takes an argument BB and the ends here
so everything ends with an end statement
and I didn't say in the introduction I
should have that the the this is not
like indentation oriented in Python you
you every code block ends with an end
statement and so actually after that the
indentation doesn't matter it's
completely irrelevant here personally I
actually prepare that at this stage but
that's up to you
right so this one prints a piece of text
and then it prints the argument value so
if I've got a value a which was 96 I
said
somewhere else and then I call foo on a
it's inside that function and it prints
the argument values 96 the type of a was
in 64
now what if I try to write a function
that takes floats so this is the this is
the notation here for saying that BB
must be a float and this is basically
how how Julia gets so fast because it
now knows that inside of this function
it only operates on floats on that
particular variable type and otherwise
it's generating multiple different
versions of the function in order to
take a float in order to take an int in
order to take a string and so on so this
one will take floats I've created it we
now have two functions called foo so if
I look at the help system okay that's
just for the print commands if I look at
the help for foo there's no
documentation because I didn't use any
dark strings for my functions but you
can see here that there's two functions
there's foo which takes a variable B B
which is a float and there's foo which
takes a variable B B and there's no
qualifier at all so it'll always use the
most specific version of the function
and it also says here where the where
the code is defined if you were in a
source file these would be actual lines
in my case it's the it's the entries in
my particular Jupiter notebook so what
if I call it on on a and then I call it
on B so the first call to foo is on the
value 96 and it prints at 96 as before
now I'm calling with a float B and I'm
still inside foo but that was a float
because that's what I told it to print
here in my definition of the second
version of foo so we're only using that
version we're not using both we're only
using that specific version of the of
the function now and we print out that
piece of text and we print out the other
argument that the new argument value
which is 15.3 we can also send it a
string and we get the generic version
and the argument value is this is a
string
okay let's see we want to talk a little
bit about what you can access and what
you can't inside of a function because
this is extremely important for
modifying variables so I've got a
function bar which takes a variable D
it's going to print the value of the
upon entering the function it then tries
to adds the value 45 to it and then it
leaves it prints the value before it
leaves the function so I'm going to
print outside of bar the value of a
before and after calling this function
so what we get is the value of a is 96
outside of the function
upon entering it's 96 just before
leaving it's 141 so the plus equals
works but it's not maintained and that's
because of how I'm accessing the memory
here with D and I'll show you now in a
second how to change that so if I look
at D instead D was this this vector so I
can also operate on a vector with this
plus equals notation and here in the
vector I'm adding what was the value 45
to every element in the vector and we
see that that that also works very well
but again it's not maintained after we
leave the function this is nice first of
all that we can operate across the
vector so simply but they're not
persistently modified now what if I
don't know if you scroll back later
you'll see in the for loop that I used
earlier I was able to persistently
change elements of a vector so if I use
a for loop here instead so instead of
using the function bar I'm now using the
function bar too and I define it here
where I prints the value before and
after doing some operations on us and
the operation is element wise across the
ad 45 so now if I take that vector I can
now change all of the elements and they
are persistent after I leave the
function so this this is quite vital to
figure out when you're actually changing
things and when you're not the idea
originally is that it's you should
typically be able to read stuff really
easily in a function but writing to them
should always be a little bit harder and
it should require a little bit more work
which is sort of a memory safer the idea
it's also about about the processing
speed and so on in this case so the last
topic here of this section is multiple
dispatch which I sort of showed you the
very first bit yep
typically yes yeah so this is this is
one of the the interesting things about
how julia is written it's much closer to
see under the hood
so typically loops are actually
extremely effective in us so the only
the only thing that's in a way more
effective is when you're using
generators and you're not even running
through the elements at that point but
know where loops are extremely optimized
so yeah it's it's actually as fast we
can you can try some timings later in
the final notebook actually I have an
example of that in the final notebook so
I've created a function bar which takes
a value D which is an array of float64
so I already had a function bar up above
and I also had a function bar - this one
is going to take an array instead of an
ax just a single float and it's going to
call bar two on that array so that's
just a way of nesting so we know that
bar two is this function here and it's
very good at operating across the across
the array elements and it can change
them persistently so now when you call
bar on on an array this it would
basically just fork the work off to this
to this particular function I could have
written the code here it was just for
playing around that I didn't there's a
methods function which will show that
there's two versions of bar there's the
one taking the array and the one taking
any other variable
there's methods of bar 2 which is just
that it takes any generic variable and
so now if I start calling a bar on a few
different values so this was on the
single value a I'm not going to enter
into how to persistently change that but
a was just a single integer in this case
and so it's not persistently changed
it's the original version of bar that
gets called on that if we now send D
which was this vector we send in this
set of 47 50 50 53 56 we see that the
values get added to it here and wait a
minute it didn't work why does it not
change our variables this is something I
wanted to show you just to show that you
have to be a little bit careful with the
types if I look at the type of D here I
have an array of in 64 s whereas I
defined bar 2 for our I designed bar
rather for float64 s so that can be a
pain in the ass at times and so I've
called I've now got to write a version
which which specializes for instance
dead and so this one will call bar 2 on
the inch and now if I call bar on D I'm
now in the version of bar which handles
int and I call bar 2 on them and we see
a well I didn't print it actually we
should see a persistent change yes
so the persistent changes here we now
see that bar has a specialization for in
specialization for floats and a generic
version as well which was the first
version I wrote and D is persistently
changed here so the last thing I wanted
to say on this particular worksheet was
a couple of take homes for people who
are thinking about this from the point
of view of other languages the base
index of the array is 1 not 0 at this
point there's almost any version of a
generator that you're familiar with will
work the kind of different notations
typically all work here white space
doesn't matter much indentation doesn't
matter at all the end keyword finishes
all kinds of code blocks whether it's a
function
whether it's a loop whether it's it's a
logic statement and less relevant for
most people but there's column-wise
memory layout here which is similar to
Fortran and so if you're doing your
loops you want to loop going down the
column first rather than across the
across the columns there's two links
here which could be quite useful for
people coming from other languages and
now I'm going to hand over to Robert
who's got his package section
King now yeah I would also say this is
already the good you need to remove the
okay basically I want to show you a
short project and I will use three
different third-party packages that are
not part of the language just to show
what kind of libraries are available
there what you might be missing if you
come from another language but first let
me tell you a little bit about the
package management so there is this
package package so it's PKG and you use
it to install and maintain packages and
the assumption is that when you develop
a package you will use git actually or
even github and when you want to publish
the package so that others can install
it you should go to this special github
repository and add a pull request and
then they will enter basically your URL
into the registry and if you have done
so you can everybody can install your
package by just saying package dot add
and then give the name of your of your
package and before you do that you
should do package dot update which will
clone this registry services say and
whenever you install a package you will
actually also clone the whole good
repository I think this is to encourage
contribution so if you fix it back
actually it can from the from the repple
you can make a full request on the
github repository if you want to install
a package that is not yet registered
there's also this package that clone
where you just give the full URL and if
you want to work on on a separate branch
you can use this package store checkout
so I think if you are familiar with kids
you will also be familiar with the
package management in Julia and then you
can do package dot status and this will
show you all of the install packages so
first it will show you the ones that you
manually install with the version and
then
it will also show those that were
installed as a dependency also with
diversion you can also see here I
checked out the master of some project
that I was working on myself so okay so
the goal of the project is to create an
index fund specifically for the dough
drone so it contains I think 30
different stocks of different weights
and I want to pick from these a couple
let's say three or four with some ways
that approximate the whole index okay
and I have some some data I think I
should execute also this
oh yeah okay so today's already showed
you that with this question mark you can
get help on functions there's also
another kind of repla metric is the
semicolon where you can just run a shell
command of course we have to do it now
but anyway there is a CSV file that I
prepared and that I think has three
columns for the date and then the name
of the stock and then the the value of
it and then in the Giulia language
itself there is a function called read
CSV and if you load it in and it will
put all the data in a single array and
you will see here it has to type any
because some strings and some are
actually numbers and it also it doesn't
really make a difference between the
header and the data so this is kind of a
low-level way of reading in the CSV file
and maybe if you come from Python or
from ru you are used to working with
data frames and in julia there's also a
package for data frames actually several
but I picked the most popular one and so
if you want to use functions from a
package you can use the using keyword
and then the name of the package are we
done here already
yeah maybe I should restart this thing
hey God slow because he tried out my
packages so can one enter and runners
you think so yeah so now we can see the
CSV file and the result of the CSV again
okay here there's no output if you run
this for the first time it will probably
pre compile it so whenever you run the
package for the first time after it was
updated it will do some compilation but
then the next time it should be fast so
data frame says the function reads table
and it will actually return something
like a table it will also print nice
here as HTML it will know about the
header and it will give you an addition
row index so here I can I can index it
like an array I can take the first row
and all the columns I can also use a
column name for example there's this
column price so this notation with the
colon and then some name is called a
symbol in Giulia and it's kind of like a
string but different and here you would
have to use the symbol and you would get
this column out of the data frame okay
so basically what I want to do is
compute the mean price for each stock
over the days of the year so that I can
get an idea of how how much they
contribute to the overall index and so
there it may be you know that this is
grouped by an aggregate approach where
you first group by the values of some
columns here it would be the symbol and
then
you get for every group you get a
basically a sub block of the table and
this one you can aggregate with a
function so there is this function
called by from the data frame package
and the first argument is the data frame
itself the next argument is the column
you want to group on and here you put
another function here you can see the
syntax for anonymous functions in Julia
you just put some variable name and then
the error and then what you want to do
with it and I will create a new data
frame that will compute a column called
average price using the mean of this d
with the price column and if I look at
the first couple of rows from that one I
can see that it there is no more any
base column there is just the symbols
and then the average price okay and now
I will normalize this to get some ways
that basically sum to one so I will just
create a new data frame and I will
create two columns one is just the old
column and the other one uses this kind
of formula I'm sorry that this is not
wrapping around so if you have used
pythons data pandas package it should
all look somewhat familiar okay and we
can also look at the data in different
ways for example we can we can pivot it
in a two way form instead of this
fledged form so this is the original
structure with the three columns but we
can also use this unstack command which
will take again the data frame and then
it will take two columns to be used for
the rows and the columns of the two-way
sheet and then another column for the
actual data inside of the cells so here
if I run this I will see that I will
have the date for the rows and then I'm
sorry this one no
scroll to fun okay you can see that it
has the date for the columns for the
road and then the different symbols for
the columns and then show the value for
the day in here and there's also a
joined like a database join because now
I want to join these ways that I've
computed with the original with the
original data frame and I will join it
on some column name here is symbol so
this is just the original name with some
with some additional column and I will
now add a column to this data frame
again using this kind of formula
notation where I just used the price and
the weight and I will multiply them
component wise so I scroll around here I
can see basically the contribution that
some stock makes up to the total dough
drones at this at this point in time and
I can take the sum of all these
contributions and then I will get what I
call the index so it's just like a
single stock that has a value over time
which is kind of the total over all the
others okay are there some questions
about the data frames part so if you if
you look into the echo system you will
see that there is I think four or five
packages that are developed in this area
and they have different benefits in
terms of performance but data frames was
there first and it's the the most
popular and the best integrated and the
others they are still kind of competing
and I hope that this development will
merge again at some point okay next I
want to go into a visualization we will
use the plots package which is actually
not a plotting package per se it's just
provides some syntax and it uses
different backends and you can basically
define the plot and then change the
backend depending on
whether you want to print it or show it
interactively with JavaScript and so on
and so here I'm using the pipe lot
package with which is actually based on
pythons matplotlib so this is the one
that many of you had problems installing
and what happens if you install the plot
the pipe lot junior package is that it
will actually generate a condor
environment and install its own Python
and mud-puddle it and then there is a
two-year package called PI call where
you can easily call Python function and
PI plot is built on that and basically
you just use the plots library and then
you call one function to initialize the
backend so let's first create some some
random data here it is it's a 10 by 3
array so it has 3 columns and if you
just do a plot of X it will consider the
3 columns to be a different series of
data and it will plot them next to each
other so we should see three lines not
sure where this is taking so much time
okay so you can see the three lines we
if we transpose this then we would have
10 columns instead and then we will see
10 lines so this is a very fundamental
concept of this Plus package if you
understand this then you can then you
can start working with it and this
concept of using the columns for series
is also applies to parameters so if you
want to change the color or the line
width or some style you can also do that
so for example I can give two colors and
then it will cycle through them so the
first one will be red the second green
and then the third one will be red again
there's also this plot with an
exclamation mark this is a convention in
Julia if some function has side effects
then there's an exclamation mark and
here it means that basically you will
add something to a previous plot so
I can build a flood with this first line
and then I can put something on top of
it he I just take the same data but I do
a plus three which we already know puts
it elementwise plus three and it should
actually show it in black and with the
different fr values and these are now
together in one choice and one chart
yeah Oh so let's say I remove it then it
will first plot the one and then the
other and I will only see the result of
the second one but what I want is that
the first one stays there and the second
one adds to the same picture basically
it's just a function name so it's really
just a convention but you will see this
in Giulia all over for example there is
the push that will add something to the
end of an array and this one also has an
exclamation mark because it will change
the array in place but there's an append
I think that will generate a new one
that doesn't have the extremism ah so
here it's just a convention and there's
two different versions of plots and one
will create a new one and the other will
reuse the previous and so what's great
about this applause package is that it
uses macros heavily to enable plotting
for your custom data types so not right
now which has put in draw arrays but
what I want to really do is plot data
frames and so there's another package
that we will use called stat plots and
it contains so called
plot recipes so it knows what the data
frame is and how to extract the arrays
from it and give it to the XO + yeah
yes
so and there's two ways of using a
package one is I with the using the
keyword and it will look at all the
exported names
and put them in the global namespace so
in a package you can explicitly say some
functions should be exported and others
not and be exported once they will come
without namespace into the into the
global one you can also use the import
instead of the using and then you would
have to prefix the name of the package
and then you would have to use set plus
dot the function name and then you will
also get access to all of them not just
the exported ones and the import one is
using the import one is important if you
want to add methods to a function so
dave has shown a function I think it was
called far and then he has added another
method with another type right let's say
there is a function in in in juliank
called
the plus operator right and you have
your own matrix type you want to
implement addition for your own matrix
type then you would have to use import
base and then do base dot plus and add
to them through the method so yeah to
answer your question if you use import
then you will has namespaces otherwise
it will come together in the global
namespace
you can also set several parameters for
multiple plots using this with
environment so here what I do is the
first plot it will take the original
data frame and it will use two columns
the date and the price kind of for the x
and y axis and it will group them by
symbol so it will show one line per
stock and Colour them gray and then I
will on top of that plot the data frame
called index with the date and value in
a little bit thicker so here you can see
basically the values of all the stocks
in the Dow Jones and then in blue the
aggregated one for the for the total
index
and what we want to do now is find one
that approximates the blue line using a
linear combination of the gray ones but
first let me show that in in the plots
package there's not only the plot
command but there's also a bar chart in
histograms and all kinds of stuff it
basically has the same the same calling
convention so here I can also show you
that instead of giving a color for the
color argument I give the name of a
column and then it will use the values
and methods to to this kind of heat map
okay now we come to the final part where
we actually do the stock picking I will
not go into the model in detail I think
that would be not in the scope of this
tutorial but what I want to do is some
kind of linear regression where I want
to minimize the L at one norm of the of
this approximation that they do so W is
my weight and P is the prices and
capital I is this index that I showed in
blue and so I want to minimize this
difference but I'm only allowed to pick
a couple of W stood and nonzero and this
can be written in a mixed integer linear
program in this form which I will not
explain now and but there is a lot of
very nice packages in in julia for doing
this kind of optimization so for example
there is packages jump and convex they
offer modeling languages basically and
then there's many julia packages for
solver back ends like these cbc is an
open source one that we will use and
then there is this math based package
that a kind of a glue with an
intermediate representation and so if
you want if you're interested in this
you should go to the website of this
two-year organization where they explain
how these packages play together for me
personally that was the reason to
actually learn julia
because in other language like Python
they have similar packages but they are
not as easy to use or as powerful okay
so I will prepare some arrays that I
will use for for indexing my decision
variables but nothing special it's just
for the symbols and for the days and
then I have a function it will create a
so-called model that is part of the jump
package it will choose a solver to use
to solve this problem and then there are
these macros to define variables for
example to the model Fund I will have a
variable pick that has one decision per
symbol and it is a binary choice so it's
a 0 1 either I take the stock or not and
so on here you can also see the Unicode
as variable names it's nice for
mathematicians and then here you can see
how I write constraints and so I
actually have a loop and I used to
constraint and then you just have the
mathematical formula using julia syntax
so i use the sum and then it's an
equation and basically the only thing
that you should take away is that this
one looks very similar to the
mathematical notation so if you go from
here and train translate it into this
one it would be very close and this is
basically what this package offers and
then I add more constraints and an
objective and I call the solve and
here's where all the magic happens
because here it will actually translate
it into the intermediate representation
of the solver back end run the solver
and extract the result and give it back
to me
so if I for example use the first
hundred days of the year for training
and I say I want to pick at most three
stocks and I will also give a time limit
of six seconds because this will take
some minutes typically I can find my
solution to solution will be an array of
of weights for different stocks so you
can see most of them are zero here three
that are nonzero I can take I can
combine them with the prices to get my
solution fund and I compare it with the
index fund using again the plots here
you can see that up to the day hundredth
day they are quite close together and
then they start diverging as we would
expect because the we didn't use this
data for the training but you can still
see that it's similar enough so maybe
our our index fund is is successful in
this respect for fun I also looked at
the at the errors that we make so here I
can use this absolute value function
point-wise on all the vector elements
and then I can do two histograms
of the errors that we make during the
training you can see they're quite small
and then up the training the red ones
you can see the errors are larger okay I
think that's for this depart for this
project are there some more questions
concerns or is it restoring one
it's just sequential and it's also so
this is not two year code that it's
running but there is this the C library
basically that has a Giulia wrapper and
this is fit the model and then cause and
run its man it's called for solving the
problem okay right so we have 15 to 20
minutes left I'm obviously not going to
do everything we should also have a few
questions at the end but that last
question is kind of relevant to what I
want to do here so I'm looking at speed
and the thing is we're using Giulia to
write the glue that holds everything
together thank you and it's it's nice
from that point of view but obviously
from speed point of view there are
libraries that have been written in the
70s in Fortran that are still being used
today for various numerical optimization
problems you don't go and rewrite those
as a package what you do instead is you
write an interface to them the interface
works extremely well because of the way
of being able to compile against these
various libraries the other thing is and
I think this is probably what Robert
means by the the syntax and he prefers
the syntax for optimization packages in
Julia compared to Python because of
things like the multiple dispatch
because of how the various macros work
it's extremely expressive from a
mathematical point of view and most
people I know who are using Julia today
are actually quite hardcore
mathematicians there they're the biggest
group of okay there's a sampling bias
here but they're strong sampling bias
but they're the biggest group I know who
are currently using it the finance
industry are kind of coming in and we'll
see now with the data science
so the first
I wanted to mention is that you can call
a C function natively so there's a
function call called C call and if I do
it here with my show macro I call the
clock function three times and the
syntax I'm only going to summarize but
basically what it is is clock is a
function to give you like ticks on the
computer and it returns an integer and
it takes zero zero parameters so you can
call it I call the three times in a row
here and you see that these numbers are
incrementing and I'd in one tick between
the calls you can see I can also call
the rand function and I get three random
numbers and I can call the printf
function and it can print my text here
blah and I can even do a slightly more
advanced call here and do the whole
interpolation of the of the printf
function so the function I'm calling
here is princess it returns in in 64
that I had to look that up to see what
it were actually returns but it's the
error code basically there's something
here that defines in in in julia called
a c string which is the first argument
to it and the second argument is in in
64 in my particular case so i send it
this this whole syntax here which anyone
from a c background would recommend
recognize so it's a string inside say
inverted commas notice that in julia
it's the double quotes that are used for
four strings my text and then there's
this percent d which then it gets
replaced in within printf it slots in
the 9999 in instant in place of this
operator so that works the more normal
way to do these c calls is to actually
wrap them inside some kind of function
here so this is an example I took from
the Julian manual where they're calling
get ends so get the environment and here
they've specified what library it sits
in and they're just doing a little bit
of error handling in case something
comes back that's that's a bit
unexpected so if I get get
on my system I've got the path and you
can see Julia's in my path and if I call
get end on some parameter which doesn't
exist it handles it very well via that
particular error function here that
opt-out basically okay so I have an
example using Young's mm-hmm yeah mm-hmm
yeah yeah so the first thing I should
say I wrote it in the text is for the
Fortran function there's one difficulty
which is Fortran compilers either
compile to uppercase function names are
lower depending on your compiler and you
have to figure out which one yours does
that's a little problem there I can't
remember how to I think it handles it's
in the interpretation in Julia here but
I actually don't remember for the for
the the erase so yeah no answer
basically okay thanks for the question
no no it's good to ask um so I mean I
have I have an example using open CL
because this is pretty hard core
parallelization and I think I would
actually leave it to after and people
can play it on their with it on their
own computers and they can ask me about
it if they want basically open CL is a C
derivative which can run parallel
computations and you can target it to a
GPU or to a seed to you is the idea and
that's why I use it extensively in my
work and the huge benefit is that you
can write the code on a computer here
which only well this computer actually
has a GPU as well but you can write it
on a computer that only has a CPU and
then you can recompile it later on a
computer where you have a GPU and it
just works straight away and it's
incredibly fast basically the example I
used here is using the open CL package
and I wrote some functions myself which
do some of the maintenance
and so on there so just if you don't
have OpenCL on your system the HTML
version of the notebook online has all
of this printed out already so you can
follow it in full you don't need to
install OpenCL and depending on your
computer it can be difficult OpenCL is
somewhat of a pain in the ass in terms
of programming that's why I have so many
of my own wrapper functions here this
the julia hook into it is so nice
specifically because you can compile
against these see things so easily but
OpenCL doesn't provide so much yourself
itself and so you tend when I wrote my
own code and see I had to write these
wrapper functions in C and now I write
them in Julia just to sort of automate a
lot of the setup than that the example I
have here is one I did on a workshop in
in March with some students and
basically it's a physics problem where
you take a single drop and you watch it
diffuse over time there the timings in
it should be able to run on any of your
computers that's why it won't diffuse so
far in this particular example but you
can run it for much longer the huge huge
benefit here is that you can use
extremely large arrays so I'm using a
five thousand by five thousand array and
I in the example I'm doing a thousand
time steps and so if I look at the text
that I've written so on my GPU that
takes 35 seconds to on the on the laptop
without it plugged in running on the CPU
to do that particular calculation is
more than five minutes and that's in
parallel on the CPU so I've done a
version where I use an array that's 25
times smaller and that takes 15 seconds
on the CPU and only 2 seconds on the GPU
the other thing is that their students
also wrote a naive version of the code
which is a CPU only version where it's
doing more or less the same calculations
I mean it's getting the same end result
and just doing it on the CPU so for the
for the small array that's 26 seconds on
my machine
compared with two seconds for four
OpenCL on the GPU and 15 seconds for
OpenCL on the cpu but I just I mean I
want to be honest here this is an
example where I made a very big array
for a smaller problem you do incur
overheads when you're shipping problems
off to the GPU and back you've got
you've got you've got to wait basically
you send a message to the GPU you have
to wait there's a pipeline whereas on
the CPU you're already operating in
cache and so on so you are operating
faster as long as you don't have a big
problem
so I also plot it and so on so the the
last thing I wanted to talk about was
kind of issues like timing and so on so
I've written a function here which does
does a loop and I can time the loop
using the time macro and so this one
took no point three not four zero three
seconds I can do a larger loop and it
takes at least three or four seconds
three seconds now I just have these
examples here because I'm doing it the
loop in different ways and basically
you'll see the different timings so for
the first loop I allocate an array of
zeros and then I give it fill out each
entry of the array in the second loop
and that took three seconds in the
second loop I just created the the
memory space I didn't actually set the
values to zero and then I said then I
set the actual values that I'm looking
for using the same method and that one
took actually fractionally longer this
time round but they're more or less the
same they're both three seconds roughly
the final one was using that
comprehension and so I left in there
creating the memory space here to show
that this is just the difference for the
loop but obviously you don't even need
to allocate the memory anymore in this
example and so when I time this one I
get a time of no point eight seconds
which is considerably faster but I use I
think roughly twice as much memory in
doing this so there is a trade-off there
there's a really really nice package
called benchmark tools which can do this
on a much wider scale and you can
program in benchmarks into your code
which are then run automatically in a
highly highly comprehensive manner the
only thing I'm showing here is running
the kind of equivalent of my timing
there again using the benchmark macro
but it's able to do much much more
complicated things than this so instead
of running time just once on the loop it
now runs the loop multiple times and it
basically it does it in an intelligent
manner so it times how long it takes and
based on variants and so on it'll it'll
decide how many times to run the loop to
create to calculate a mean and so on so
in the simple loop the memory estimate
used is like seven hundred and sixty Meg
they it's 2.2 seconds roughly for most
of the runs and it did three runs the
second one should come in pretty similar
yep so it's again seven hundred and
sixty Meg and it's it's about two point
something seconds and the final one
which was the really fast one went
around time so now we just get to see
compared to three seconds and compared
to the memory here we get to see how
long it takes so it's 1.4 gigabytes
rather than 760 Meg that's pear run
that's not like that's not over the over
the total but it's only taking 700
milliseconds and it ran this seven times
rather than three because it found some
kind of variance in it one it needed to
check you can do this on on other
functions I don't know that it's
necessary and there's also a profiler
built into the system so I can profile
what my loops do so here I initialize
the profiler
I run the loop but I decided here to
clear the profile again and now I run it
again but this time with the profiler
macro on so that line is running right
now on those two two loops and then I'm
going to reuse this profile view to view
the output of that
and I should be able to get a nice
picture so look it's not going to be the
best on this screen there's there's a
lot more over the other side which I can
see when I get the screen right but I
won't play with it now
and I have to keep my hands off of it
okay so there is a profiler there is a
debugger but as I said at the start of
the talk they just the guy who's writing
it hasn't updated isn't in time for
today the new version of Julie only came
out last week but it runs pretty much
like any debugger you can set
breakpoints you can set breakpoints at a
line in the code or on entry to a
function or on specific conditions and
yeah basically hopefully you can you can
play with that if you actually have a
need for that in your programming I
think we're going to stop there are
there any questions before we wrap up I
mean particularly you guys are coming
here because you're somewhat curious
we've tried to give you the full
overview which is crazy but at the end
of the day when you don't know the
language you sort of need to know the
basics and then on the other hand we
also want to show you some advanced
topics because it's more interesting for
us what is it what is it you need to
know so yeah did you have the microphone
yeah any diffusion example do you have
some variable x in python maybe was know
maybe in your office Tamir if you have I
mean what would you what would you write
it and you mean you you mean numpy
really rather than Python I guess get an
idea of how fast this is I mean it's it
the problem is it's very hard to compare
because between languages because it's
it's usually an unfair comparison you
you know I'll use some trick some the
guy who writes for the other language
will eventually figure out a better
trick on his language and so on if
you've written it super efficiently and
all the rest in numpy it should be
roughly on the order of the
the naive implementation here because
that is the speed on a single single
threads once you go to the open CL stuff
your parallel even on the CPU so I would
expect non play to be if you really
write it well it should be comparable to
to Julia for the core processing on top
of that you do have the overhead of of
theis and in general so whatever else
you're doing everything is scripted and
so on so know the numpy is is very fast
but pison is not what's or one more I'm
surprised nobody else is Julia ready for
use but that's okay I guess you're all
convinced actually tackling on that idea
so what would you say is the the biggest
limitation so the thing you like the
less the least right now change it's
it's it's getting there but it's not
stable enough and I get a bit of noise
with the core developers they're a tight
group sitting together at MIT they're
doing all the right things but when you
can't see the roadmap and you know that
they're going to change some of the core
features in the future you don't know
when and you don't know how that's
that's painful it's painful to upgrade
the software and then see some warning
deprecation on your codes so that's
that's a humongous pain in the ass it
would be nice if they were like
Microsoft and they would release the
definition of Nash three years before
the actual language appeared but they
are only like six to eight people and I
would say four in terms of speed and
efficiency and everything else they are
making the right decisions but you know
I can't wait for version one basically
you know so I would see it as a huge
competitor to MATLAB in the long run and
and to all kind of data science tools in
general but the thing that's going to
hold most of you back is the fear that
the language is not stable and that
something is going to change and
especially you know
got your work slow the changes are
getting smaller and smaller but you'd
rather not come along when your boss
asks you to do something and realize
that your upgrade kills something that
you were already using for for the last
year or so so I think we go to stop
there and hand over to the next people
so actually it's a break time right so
yeah enjoy the break
[Applause]